je ne céderai pas je ne me rendrai pas
il y a 5 ans la campagne présidentielle
est marqué par l'affaire Fillon avec un
rebondissement en plein salon de
l'agriculture
[Musique]
à l'époque le candidat de la droite
François Fillon est accusé d'avoir donné
un emploi fictif à sa femme et à ses
enfants mais malgré cette affaire il
poursuit sa campagne il prévoit d'aller
au salon de l'agriculture passage obligé
pour tous les candidats mais le matin de
sa visite il annule au dernier moment ce
matin à la surprise générale François
Fillon annule sa visite au salon de
l'agriculture sur place les membres de
son équipe et ses soutiens semblent un
peu désappointé
l'équipe de François Fillon est
tellement désemparée que le directeur de
campagne Bruno Retailleau passe sa
matinée à esquiver les questions des
journalistes de Public Sénat je suis au
taillot est-ce que vous ne regrettez pas
quand même l'absence de François Fillon
tous les matins
tous les matins je prends mon lait de
vache et je le sucre avec du miel
ah le miel ça peut adoucir l'amertume de
certaines journées alors ce matin-là
François Fillon n'est donc pas au salon
d'agriculture mais à 12h30 coup de
théâtre il organise une conférence de
presse à son sujet de campagne et il a
des choses à dire
que je serai convoqué afin d'être mis en
examen je ne céderai pas je ne me
rendrai pas je ne me retirerai pas
j'irai jusqu'au bout parce qu'au-delà de
ma personne c'est la démocratie qui est
défié la mise en examen de François
Fillon c'est un vrai tournant dans sa
campagne il durcit son discours
vis-à-vis de la justice qui est pourtant
un pilier la démocratie après cette
conférence de presse nouveau
rebondissement dans cette journée
finalement François Fillon décide
d'aller au salon d'agriculture
le salon de l'agriculture à 15h à ses
côtés un important service de sécurité
et des militants venus le soutenir
[Musique]
des filles présidents aussitôt couverts
par des en prison
cette affaire Fillon c'est le naufrage
d'un candidat qui avait misé sur
l'exemplarité au début de sa campagne
pendant la primaire de la droite il
avait même taclé Nicolas Sarkozy sur ce
point en lançant à la tribune qui
imagine un seul instant le général de
Gaulle mise en examen en tout cas en
pleine campagne présidentielle les
autres candidats ne se gêne pas pour
l'enfoncer il faut pas mettre toute la
classe politique et tous les projets
politiques dans cette même situation je
suis désolé de vous le dire on peut
décider de porter un projet pour
l'avenir de notre pays de répondre à la
détresse qui existe d'être ambitieux
pour la France et ne pas être dans le
même sac que celles et ceux qui ont eu
ces comportements et qui décident
aujourd'hui de continuer en effet à se
comporter de manière je pense largement
incompréhensible pour bon nombre de nos
concitoyens 3 ans plus tard François
Fillon et sa femme ont été condamnés 50
prisons dont deux fermes pour l'ancien
Premier ministre 3 ans avec sursis pour
son épouse ils ont fait appel verdict en
mai 2022
[Musique]